I don't know if you guys know about the,
uh,
the daycare scandals that,
that were very,
very common in the 1980s so horribly common,
actually this infested many towns.
And usually what would happen is somebody who is a little on the paranoid side
or maybe a lot of on the paranoid side would send their children off to daycare.
And that was a whole new thing in the 80s,
right?
Because women were,
you know,
moving into the workforce like mad and so they were handing over there often
their infants kids below three say two total strangers.
And you know,
for some of them that set up a fair bit of worry.
Like it still does.
And sometimes that word got out of hand,
especially among the people who are a little on the little predisposed to
paranoid schizophrenia.
And maybe even had had some previous episodes.
And so,
you know,
the kid would come home and the mother would observe or not something kind of
peculiar about their behavior.
And then she'd fantasize about maybe what that was.
And then,
you know,
she started asking the child if the child had been touched in any particular way
and you know,
and she keep this up for a good length of time.
And then the child would start to have nightmares and then the child would tell
the mother about what the nightmares were and then that would freak her out.
And so she'd ask even deeper questions and soon,
you know,
her children were telling her that horrible things were happening to them at
daycare.
And so then she'd go to the police and they wouldn't look into recycling Patrick
background.
And then the police would go out and they'd start to interview other children.
And if they interviewed them properly,
then the other children would start to produce all these stories as well because
the now how did that happen?
Well,
a bunch of ways.
The first is
the police would ask leading questions like,
did anyone touch you?
Well,
of course I'm going to touch the cans.
I mean,
people touch kids.
Did anybody touch you there?
Well,
that's not a question.
That's a piece of information.
The piece of information is if someone touched me there and adult would be very
interested in that,
right?
So what now,
what's a child doing when he's answering and adults questions?
Wealth child doesn't bloody well know what the hell do they know?
They're like three.
You know,
they can't hardly organize their story.
if you're talking to a kid and you want to give,
get them to give you an account of their day,
you have to really guide them through the Organization of their memory.
And partly what they're doing when you're doing that is they're looking at you
trying to figure out if they're telling you the right things,
which is what they should be doing.
Because what they're trying to learn to do is to tell people things in a way
that they'll understand them.
But that makes the child very,
very responsive to the nonverbal and verbal cues of the adult.
You think about how fast those little rats learn how to pick up language.
You know,
it's really very fast and no one really teaches them.
They're just paying attention like mad.
So you get a bunch of cops who were on how like a half cocked adventure and they
think there's some serial sexual pervert in their midst and they go interview,
you know,
1520 kids and they do do,
do it,
do it a lot.
They use the little dolls and they do it a lot and they do it a lot and they do
a lot and sooner or later all the kids start having nightmares and then they
start telling the carbs.
There's all these terrible things happen,
like they're taking into underground caverns and they're stripped naked and
they're forced to like leap frog over each other and like you just can't believe
it.
What happened?
You can't believe it.
It's all documented in a book called Satan's silence,
which was written by a social worker and a lawyer.
It's mind boggling.
The longest prison sentence is in American history were handed out to it to a
series of middle aged women who are taking care of little kids and the FBI even
came up with a whole new criminal category,
late onset,
female sexual offender.
Well,
why didn't that category exist before?
It's simple.
There are no late onset,
middle aged female sexual offenders.
That's why we didn't need the category.
But once all these accusations came up,
well poof,
you know,
you had to have some damn category for these poor women.
Some of them were put in jail for 350 years,
which seems a bit excessive given that they're only going to last about 40,
you know,
they get 12 consecutive life sentences.
So it,
and you know,
there was actually a situation where one town went so far as to start digging
underneath the town to find these underground,
say tannic layers where all these weird ritual things were going on,
you know,
and along with this was not one shred of Collab of concrete evidence,
on the eventual conclusions and disaffected thousands of people.
The eventual conclusions was,
well,
they're,
there actually isn't anybody who's,
you know,
saint technically,
uh,
torturing children in daycare centers.